Question is regarding injections. Is it
permitted during the fast?
>> As far as injections are concerned,
there are different types of injections.
It can be intravenous injection. It can
be intramuscular injection. It can be
subcutins injection. But the injections
can broadly be classified in two types.
One type of injection which gives a
person a nourishment which is equivalent
to giving food. For example, if you take
an intravenous glucose to people who
have excessive dehydration etc and
cannot take food by the mouth. So
normally the medical treatment is giving
intravenous glucose. This is sort of
nourishment. It is equivalent to giving
food. This will break the fast. But if
it's not a nourishment, if it's only a
medical treatment like insulin, it can
be subcutaneously or it is penicellin.
All these medical treatments which are
not nourishment to the body are not
somewhat like food. These can be given
during the daytime and the fast will not
break. Though there are some scholars
who say that it's makru or discouraged.
It's preferable if it's taken after the
sunset. But the right ruling is that it
does not break the fast because it's not
any sort of